so und wir schalten jetzt zum ersten Mal
live nach Berlin zu meinem Kollegen
Bernd rasem der für uns die
Veranstaltung Aufstand für Frieden
beobachtet hallo Bernd schildern Sie uns
die Situation vor Ort
also wir sind jetzt direkt vor dem
Brandenburger Tor hier findet ja die
Veranstaltung statt Alfred schier sie
haben es ja schon gesagt so kurz nach 14
Uhr wird es losgehen dann wird alles
schwarzer ähm die eine der mit
Initiatorinnen sie wird dann eine kurze
Eröffnungsrede halten und dann werden
diverse Redner erwartet eben unter
anderem es ist schwarze aber auch Sarah
wagenknechte momentan das kann man so
sagen es ist leichter Schneefall hier in
Berlin also keinen besonders angenehmes
Wetter recht kühl ungefähr 1000 Menschen
haben sich jetzt hier mittlerweile vor
dem Brandenburger Tor eingefunden und es
werden aber schon deutlich mehr also man
konnte auf den Straßen hier rechts und
links schon deutlich zu laufen sehen und
ja auch die Polizei ist mit der ganze
Menge Kräften vor Ort
einen Eindruck gewinnen können was für
Menschen das sind wer an dieser
Demonstration teilnehmend
ich habe mal mit einigen vor dieser
Veranstaltung gesprochen repräsentativ
ist das auf keinen Fall aber was
auffällig ist ist dass viele Menschen
gesagt haben sie fühlen sich keiner
politischen Gruppierungen zugeordnet es
sind mehrere dabei gewesen die gesagt
haben sie kommen aus der
Friedensbewegung der 80er Jahre
beispielsweise wir erinnern uns noch
damals nahezu doppelbeschluss also das
waren Dinge die mir teilweise genannt
worden sind
bekannt zum Beispiel das war ja auch ein
Thema was hier im Vorfeld dieser ganzen
Veranstaltung immer wieder diskutiert
wurde wie stark beispielsweise ganz
rechte Gruppen dort mit auftreten werden
ich habe bisher da noch nichts
feststellen können aber wie gesagt die
Veranstaltung ist ja erst ganz am Anfang
aber ich möchte jetzt mal weil die Frage
war ja wer wird erwartet Anja dierschke
sie ist von der Polizei Berlin die
Pressesprecherin wen erwarten sie denn
hier welche Gruppen haben sich denn aus
ihrer Sicht hier angekündigt
es ist einmal zum Großteil wirklich die
Breite bürgerliche Mitte die hier ihre
Meinung auf die Straße tragen möchte
aber wir gehen auch davon aus weil es
gab bundesweite Mobilisierung in ganz
unterschiedliche
politische Richtung dass eben auch
andere Menschen hier teilnehmen werden
corona-maßnahmen Kritiker auch
verschwörungsideologische Tendenzen sind
hier zu erwarten was aber grundsätzlich
kein Problem darstellt denn wenn alle 11
nämlich eine Botschaft auf die Straße zu
tragen und das friedlich miteinander
dann ist das kein Problem
sie sagen alles kein Problem trotzdem
sind wir ziemlich starken Kräften vor
Ort habe ich heute morgen gelesen mit
wie viel Beamten sind sie denn hier und
warum so viele wir sind mit rund
1 heute hier in der Stadt anlässlich der
Einsatzlage unterwegs aber wir kümmern
uns ja nicht nur um die Kundgebung hier
auf dem Platz des 18 März sondern es
gibt noch eine Reihe anderer
Veranstaltungen Aufzüge die wir
begleiten werden und dann geht es
natürlich auch um den Schutz des
Regierungsviertels und andere Objekte
die schützenswert sind mit wie viel
Teilnehmern rechnen sie denn eigentlich
insgesamt am Ende für diese
Veranstaltung hier auf Platz des 18 März
erwartet die Anmelderin 10.000
teilnehmende aufgrund der bundesweiten
Mobilisierung sind wir aber auch darauf
vorbereitet dass es mehr werden das ist
sicherlich auch ein bisschen
wetterabhängig das muss man so sagen
aber wir sind darauf vorbereitet dass es
auch deutlich mehr werden können jetzt
habe ich mich ja gefragt im Vorfeld
gaben sich ja auch gab es ja immer
wieder Überlegungen das ja
möglicherweise auch Rechtsextreme dran
teilnehmen an dieser Veranstaltung wenn
ich mir mal die Masse angucke was machen
Sie denn wenn sie dort rechtsextreme
Symbole beispielsweise sehen eigentlich
müssen sie ja einschreiten werden sie
das tun oder würden Sie sagen bei
angesichts der Masse lieber nicht es
gibt der grundsätzlich zur Teilnahme an
dieser Veranstaltung bestimmt Auflagen
bestimmte Symbole die nicht gezeigt
werden dürfen das wird von meinen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen auch im
Nahbereich überprüft und bei jeder
Straftat die uns bekannt wird die von
uns gesehen wird werden wir auch
konsequent einschreiben sie sprechen für
die Polizei aber natürlich auch für den
Staatsschutz welche Erkenntnisse hat der
ihn im Vorfeld übermittelt was dürfen
sie dazu sagen tatsächlich wurde
natürlich inwieweit eine Mobilisierung
rechtsextremer hier heute eine Rolle
spielen könnte dazu gibt es aber
tatsächlich keine Hinweise Anja dirschke
von der Polizeipressestelle erstmal
herzlichen Dank für diese Einordnung wir
können ja später noch mal dann im
Verlaufe der Demonstration Kontakt
aufnehmen um dann eventuell auch noch
mal ihnen zu berichten beispielsweise
wie es tatsächlich ist wie die
Veranstaltung verläuft und ob es
tatsächlich dann so friedlich verläuft
wie man in diesem Moment zumindest hofft